I think it's a good sign if this is most
people's favorite this is a new and
different experience the more you know
who you are and what you want to us
hi Harrison and IRAs doodle jam we go
which good do you are playing with me Oh
precious oh look at the face
hey Hari oh good
short little run along the beach in
Malibu to start what is going to be
pretty active day well I'm down in
Malibu I thought I'd check out my buddy
Andrews art show you know Andrew from
the Airstream dude no art patrons at ten
o'clock in the morning it's not even
open yet oh ma lady in here yeah it's
right there lady Lily this is Kitson
right so I was leaving and Andrew texted
me said it's open now so I ran back
check it out first ones in in the
morning tell me what's your or dude what
is struck hear me will actually keep
from cycling some of your audience might
know that if somebody gets hit on the
road by a car passes away they put like
one of those ghost bikes up you know
like a white bikes right sometimes they
have a little sign attached and that
says struck here and I kind of you know
you see these in the area occasionally
right so I got interest with the idea of
like you know how everything can change
in that one one second and so it could
be inspiration it could be you know
whatever it is but you're struck at that
moment the USDA are as you know because
it's usually in your house you know I
have a ten year history working with the
USDA I got a little bit disillusioned of
what organic was supposed to be and what
it is now because evolved like the
corporate interests and lobbying money
and power and so yeah the series is
based off of that everyone has their
favorite this wedding night I think it's
a good sign if this is most people's
favorite Andrew Pasquale boom flash it
up everybody father art all right miss
Ella tickle
thanks for stopping by
I'm at playboy
about to do radio show this is a new and
different experience should be
interesting what do I say I sit here I
want you there here on the couch
but Playboy Radio begin was it all right
oh no that was fantastic perfect I can
say my thing all day long but I'm not
with ultra runner especially men hearing
it oh you such an elite athlete
you listened dan was it all right it was
all right good marble is super fun it's
weird to come to playboy and then talk
about like being vegan well Disney of
the show is sexy beasts witches under
the Playboy umbrella people want to be
and if we want to be the sexiest
versions of ourselves that starts
unlearning what we've been brainwashing
to write the words want to be super sexy
like you are you have to start adopting
a more plant-based lifestyle I would
have never guessed in a million years
that when I first started this journey
training for Ultraman going vegan that
one day I would be doing media at
Playboy
it's just so bizarre no Trevor you drive
you want to blog this
so we're out here in Malibu Creek State
Park shooting some running stuff for a
video project that we're working on this
is kind of like one of my backyard
trails one of my go-to is where I do a
lot of training pretty extraordinary
look at these mountains valleys there
are just hundreds of square miles back
here you can explore and run to your
heart's content
incredibly beautiful picturesque
landscape to get some pretty epic
running shots work with the drone and
the Ronin which is like this gimbal
contraption we're shooting some slow-mo
stuff it's super cool
all this drone shooting is exhausting
there's more exhausting than just
training it's incredible that I have
access to this literally just down the
street from where I live it's like
training paradise and it's kind of a
little known secret in Los Angeles not
that many people even know that it's
here there's rarely anybody out here
just a few people on a daily basis that
I see tons of deer and coyotes and
wildlife and its really pristine and
beautiful
job after you I really need to be here
sweet yeah
pretty girl somebody girl loved it in
1998 things were looking pretty bleak
for me it was the height of my drinking
and my drug addiction and at that time
there were essentially three paths for
my life it was either going to be jail
an institution or death and by some
miracle I found my way to sobriety and
today I live this incredible life a life
that is so full and so rich essentially
I have this gift of being able to get up
every day and do something I love
whether it's shooting a video like we
were doing today needing somebody and
having a conversation for the podcast
traveling to do a speaking engagement
working on a book or any number of other
creative endeavors and I try really hard
to not lose sight of not only how lucky
I am
but how grateful I am to be able to do
these things to live this life that I
have but behind all of it it's also
important to understand that I did work
really hard for it the life that I enjoy
today is a result of seeds that I
planted as far back as 1998 when I got
sober when I left corporate law firm
life in the early 2000s a series of so
many decisions that I've made over the
last 18 years that have led to this
point and along the way there was doubt
there was suffering there was trauma
there was tremendous difficulty there
was dismantling there were financial
problems so that's why I think at times
it can be very easy or very Cavalier to
tell somebody quit your job chase your
passion it's not always that simple you
have to really ask yourself how many
obstacles are you willing to endure are
you in it for the long haul
because
it's not going to be easy nothing good
and valuable in life comes easy and
that's why I call it the Warriors path
but if you have the courage if you have
the tenacity if you have the willingness
to weather
the long journey ahead then I simply
can't think of anything more gratifying
or meaningful to embark upon if you
begin to express something that you're
passionate about in your life or
something that has deep personal meaning
and begin to cultivate and bring that to
life that simple act alone will catalyze
a journey for you and if you begin to
follow those threads I can assure you
that the path that lies ahead is paved
with a lining of personal satisfaction
and meaning and to me that's the prize
you